what
my name is booyah and welcome to I'm
really sorry I haven't done news in a
while I feel like I miss you breath but
I miss your smell I miss your laughter I
miss your beautiful eyes there that was
officially the most awkward way to start
an episode um I don't know why it's so
hard for me to make this sometimes it's
actually the most easiest video ever for
me to record but I also feel like it's
the most important video for me to do so
I feel bad for not doing it because this
is my chance to talk to you bros my
subscribers and just see what's up so
you'd see what's filling on the grilling
as I just made up it will most likely
just be me talking but I do read all the
comments and I you know by I'm gonna I
want to share with you breasts Thanks
knife like this is chewing gum on them
and I'm ice cream stick there you go you
are welcome
anyway let's get serious first of all I
want to say thank you brother so much so
much for one and a half million
subscribers I have never even thought
we'd reach a million so the fact that
we're still growing so rapidly is that
it's it's insane for me I can't thank
you guys enough for all the support I
feel like since I haven't done one of
these in a while I want to just strip
off the hog pig crate a bad thing and
just be like hey I add that this is so
stupid I'm sorry um my name is Felix I
come from Sweden I'm 22 years old
I am my favorite food is chicken and my
favorite color is red on things actually
it's blue so what about yourself tell me
I want enough basically I seen so many
like Sims reason girl from YouTube I
know that this is gonna happen sooner or
later but there's a lotta
I don't know less mature comments coming
in everywhere but hey what can you do
about it people tend to hear things
about people and then you just believe
whatever they want but I've seen
comments people say goodbye sucks which
is fine you can have Europe that is fine
I will kill you later [ __ ] don't you
dare [ __ ] sex are okay and PewDiePie
is swedish which is actually true so
very very good remark there sir
good pie doesn't care about his fans you
know you bros know I love you know I'm
nothing without you I know this and um I
I really really appreciate everything
you do I spent so much time reading
comments and you know
just trying to understand where you were
coming from and everything that tell me
I love talking to you brother and then I
get people saying oh I only care about
money and all I ever done and all I ever
wanted to do with YouTube is to make
videos and have fun and that's what I'm
there that's it so it's weird for me
that all these kind of things come out
of nowhere
especially when people say baby you
gotta control your fans what is up and
it's like there's one and a half million
people right now
there are many smart people most of them
watch my channel and they are the true
bros but then of course there are some
people who do things that I don't like
but I can help it I can't I can't tell
people what to do I can't help it boom
and what not to do it's really weird for
me how all these things come out of
nowhere because all I'm doing is making
videos
I'm not provoking anyone I'm not trying
to harass anyone I generally feel bad
for you I'm sorry if you spend time all
day riding in my comments mean stuff you
know after I'm done listening to Simple
Plan Britney Spears and Justin Bieber
you know I generally feel bad for you
because there's gotta be something
better going on in your life but today
don't get me wrong I appreciate the
extra views I really do it's great so
yeah I just wanted to make that clear
thank you for listening
I'm gonna weigh again I'm sorry I'm
always going away I really really don't
want to go away but there are people in
my life who are important I have family
I have friends and my girlfriend and I
are having our anniversary and
she's I promised her I promised my guy
friend lies died so long that we would
go together on the trip but it just
never happened because I'm always
working on YouTube I'm always making
these videos and that I love doing that
I that's why I'm always doing it but
since it's our anniversary and Paris is
really close and that's her dream town
to go to I wanted to surprise her on
going there so we're going there for
three days
so basically ever since I met Martha my
life has become so much better it's been
the best year of my life
I love you Matt yeah and I feel like
since June she's always so supportive
mean with me putting up so much time
with YouTube but I think this is the
least I can do for her
I hope you bros understand that
sometimes I just can't make videos this
is how it is I'm sorry there's been more
of that later this month but it's not
gonna be like this all a lot of talk
this episode I'm sorry I just want to
say a final thank you both for being so
supportive I can't tell you how much it
means to me especially now that I'm
doing other stuff besides horror usually
when people just do like one thing like
FPS games or minecraft they're found
bound to do these things and when they
stop playing it people just don't care
or be like what the hell are you doin
this is not minecraft why aren't you
building blocks [ __ ] sorry that
was my take on average my grand fan
thumbs I probably found a microphone to
watch this on I'm sorry if I offended
you a lot my best game ever me a notch
ever bromance going on now if you're
watching this so yeah and I don't
remember what I was talking about but
hey oh yeah
to the moon epic let's play glad you
bros enjoy it anyway have you seen one
of these before and means it's time to
brofist
you're a true bro you seen it alright
stay awesome bros but let's you know
people say bad [ __ ] about girls only 12
year olds in the fan base you know what
[ __ ] um this is how we do
magic crisis all right
sales and rest I know you will man come
on activate